- [Voiceover] Let's figure out
what 2.211 divided by 6.7 is.
So the first thing I like to do is,
I don't like to divide by a decimal.
So I'm going to multiply 6.7,
I'm going to multiply 6.7 by 10,
which is essentially
just taking this decimal
and moving it one space to the right.
Well I can't just do that to the 6.7,
I also have to do that to the 2.21.
So let me move its decimal
one space to the right.
And so now I can rewrite the problem.
I can rewrite it as
22,
22 point,
22.11
divided by,
instead of writing it as 6.7
I can now write it as 67.
67, let me do it in that same color.
I could write a decimal right over here
but that's not going to change the fact
that this is just now the whole number 67.
And so now I'm ready to
do some long division
now that I'm dividing by a whole number.
You might say, "Wait, I still
have a decimal over here,"
but that's okay
and you're going to see that in a second.
So let's try to do some long division.
So we're going to take,
we're going to take 22.11
or 22 and 11 hundredths,
and we are going to divide,
let me write that a little bit bigger
just so we have some space.
22.11,
and we are going to divide that by...
We are going to divide that by 67.
67.
Alright, let's do some long division now.
And actually, before we even do that,
I like to keep track of my decimal.
So my decimal is over here,
I'm going to write my
decimal right over here
in the answer.
And when you're doing these
long division problems
it's really important
to write things neatly
and keep things in nice columns
and keep track of your place value
because if you don't write
things in neat columns
then frankly you'll probably
lose track of your place value.
But let's do this.
So 67 goes into 2 zero
times, so let's move on.
67 goes into 22 zero times.
67 goes into 221.
So let's think about that a little bit.
This is pretty close to 70,
70 times 3 would be 210.
So this looks like maybe three times,
three times seems about right.
So let's try, let's put a 3 up here.
3 times 7 is 21,
carry the 2,
3 times 6 is 18, plus 2 is 20,
is 20.
So we get 201 and the difference between
221 and 201 is going to be...
Well you just get a 0
here, you get a 2 here,
then you get a 0 here, I
don't have to write it.
It's 20.
So 3 was right, if 3 times
67 were higher than 221
then we'd be in trouble.
And then if 3 times 67 were
lower but it was so low
that when you subtracted you
got a number higher than 67
then that means you could have thrown in
more 67s in there, but
this number's just right.
It's lower but our remainder is less than,
is less than 67, so let's keep going.
So now we can bring down,
we can bring down the 1
and we see 67 goes into 201,
well we just figured that out.
67 goes into 201 three times, three times.
3 times 7 is one, carry the 2,
gotta make sure we don't...
Well, if we're doing the
same problem as we did before
but it's good to not have
the previous 2 there,
sometimes you might want to erase it.
Then you have 3 times
6 is 18 plus 2 is 20.
And now you subtract, and we are done
because we have no remainder
and there's nothing
here left to bring down.
And so
22.11 divided by 67 is...
And we can throw a 0 here
just for good measure.
It's 0.33.
0.33, this is equal to 0.33.
Or this is equal to 0.33.
And we're done.